[Music]
how's it going red my name is free
hardback last episode we met Stefano in
this schedule thing and I myself I
respond it was we have to go save the
world with the sledgehammer
I'm just saying retribution
[ __ ] whoa look at that [ __ ] so
I can freaking roller coaster whoa
someone out there I have a cell phone
and a VP watch it you walk these are my
little afraid of monsters like in the
ending all right I guess we have your
job
like a boss hey I made it that's not
whoa whoa whoa I know it hides but
that's life whoa whoa whoa hello all
right
how you doing how are you doing sir
lovely weather [ __ ] I knew that won't
happen I have a VP [ __ ] says up
here oh it's heaven all right I'll just
go to heaven
lovely oh no they say in heaven it is
alright what like a bass the hell is
that
vagina rollercoaster all right
whoa it is a no sir I'm not going there
what do healers - whoa whoa whoa I ain't
going they all right let's go here whoa
whoa whoa freaking roller coaster what
the hell scope whoa all right I'm going
down there
what the hell is going on here
Shh quiet be quiet all of you
now where the heck am I supposed to go
now are you serious are you serious
right out there all right
No ah [ __ ] it's difficult I say don't go
back ladies and gentlemen
jump
all right let's try to keep up the pace
here you went yeah right
whoa whoa whoa rollercoaster don't [ __ ]
with me all right and then here nah son
of a-- okay time to focus there we go
nama Nima's problemas then we jump there
we go no problem in the end even dear oh
look at this hello how you doing in that
splendid all right and then this is
really oh that's here well isn't that
lovely
Shh I know you're upset about being in a
cage but cage aren't that bad you know
wait did I start here or something sure
as hell hope not
ah son of a it's difficult don't judge
me but you're sitting there like it's so
easy
ah I need I need to lose weight I think
I should I'm coming back all right come
on come on baby
watch hat like a bass all right come on
baby
whoa emoji that's a lot of doors which
one should I choose
I think this like about I don't know
what the hell that was about but it was
creepy I don't like it out
oh now I think it's time to bring out
the sledgehammer Stockholm City
alright let's go in here I don't trust
it Oh No all right so book car route
handicap let's go to the handicap ramp
all right a note for me hey my life that
fateful night the child lay upon the
road broken why do you have to walk that
late so what young man why do you have
to be so foolish delusion and him kidded
by his parents words long the child was
broken physically broken mentally the
man in the white placed him in the
rolling chairs howler Hydra rolling
chairs as her arias he so lived her
remains of lies and one day lon
faith sorry smiled upon the child and so
he became a barn implement of the
crucians decisions decisions
the outcome was not certain prickle
ecology Baca sulphate a syllabary my
life beautiful sorry
alright we're back and I did not cheat
or anything like I thought it guess it's
car first
and then we'll share is this the other
two I don't really understand but I
since I didn't cheat wait I forgot
was it gun and then book let's just
[ __ ] hope so where are you mr. Burke
please be right ah I can't even if I
cheat well isn't that splendid let's try
again
wheelchair I don't need to cheap it's
just all right gun and then buk buk
where are you baby
and now it's like baby yeah sons of
[ __ ]
alright save station look at this
should I really go down here I don't
think it's a good idea but let's do it
anyway oh no like a comedians we regret
this decision why did I let me go back
up place it seems alright well what the
hell are you
oh I have such ever please back off
oh no no no senorita Phil the Congo
running with my sledgehammer like a whoa
what the hell was that a fish
no I don't think that was a fish but
it's okay you will not serve I know ha
I'm up for the challenge
son of a penis all right all right
left I mean right whatever left all
right Rodney like about round like about
it on the bottom about that whoa
feel the Congo what I know I don't know
father
all right I feel this a limit all right
no problem no problem no problem no
problem on happy place Tigers and
unicorns love that [ __ ]
all right this way left nope what the
hell is that's a map
I can't even no no okay to the left who
lived and then they don't I don't want
them to sneak up on me the little father
it should be pretty straight forward
from here actually
I understand the map correctly
which I sincerely hope sonic son I don't
really want a enjoy yourselves good I'm
not good Salieri time follow my mom
right now sick of this [ __ ] can I want
my money back from your mom are you sick
whoa that's the accent I [ __ ] made it
for you
they said fishy this is no time to argue
hey Chang don't you bet your don't you
dare come this way dealer's occupation
they should still mess with a surprise
right Peter that's right I flashback
romantic problems I don't see anything
wrong with that
I mean I was pretty normal stop now
Simon Simon don't you dare quit on me
now you let the [ __ ] Nolan efficient
pilot gah now Simon that's right son
well done well done Simon hey [ __ ]
made it
yeah I agree with you those little
fishes look delicious
ah not really I made it pretty well I
think
he's still there
who don't look don't look
whoa that is great I don't remember
actually it's obvious something else
happens I get the feeling something else
will happen
chapter five leaving for what are you
doing down there
oh no this means killing that's killed
with the BP all right [ __ ] I think
it's better if you use this well
actually don't shoot me boy I told you
make my strafing skills there we go like
a bash know when they explode this
beautiful bow there's like a million of
them holy [ __ ]
there we go like Abbas backup your
native sheds oh no oh no saving skills
craving skills [ __ ] Paula shut your
beautiful who's shooting me all right
bad become a lag regular bad [ __ ] me
so to get for not hugging me properly
all right am I gonna sleep
no I'm not where's the other one I saw
another one there you are ma'am
Oprah Oh brah you just gotta go with
Oprah that's just how it is
all right give me that [ __ ] let me go up
I feel so bad for a barber master it
doesn't look like it was one of those
things from barber master
a quest
all right this way I got this ha watch
out we got a badass over here right the
knight come from here
why did I go for this hell I'm taking
those little inventory fall but what
should I drop I don't want to drop
anything I just get the feeling I will
need those [ __ ] fuses let's do a save
users in case we have to go back here
all right come in hurt a lion scare
can't injure yet to cambric so why the
heck am I supposed to go
[Music]
and we going back
they're nowhere they can tell us what
we're doing
they bring in here alright I don't
really know where to go I think we will
end this episode here I can favorite to
be enjoyed subscribe to become a breath
today and I'll see you next episode
alright
[Music]
Hey